oui
ouais
depuis il me tim thomas et n'a toujours
connu lazare est en ruine
mais au début on avait la famille tes
amis tes habite dedans et dans la
sérénité n'était joué russie compte et y
ils savent à mon camarade 18 dans la rue
pour nous avant une piste un bâtiment
commun à toutes les façons l'histoire
mais après vraiment qu'on a comme
comment commence travail en bas l'ama a
pu connaître son histoire son passé et
n'a qu on a travaillé dessus
on a fait beaucoup de découvertes comme
quoi le niveau du sol tout ça ne
découvre des escaliers vidéo rôle
important des trucs que le dieu du côté
patrimoine qui la découvrent nous te one
ou le passé nous ancêtres
voilà mes appels françois c'est
l'habitat la grande chaloupe mais avant
ça méritait pas ici mais la rencontre
quelqu'un est malade mais habite si à la
base métallique au chaudron et la grande
chaloupe c'est une découverte
parce que
l'amant prix que laver le mot ne pas
engager ici et à la base mais tu connais
pas du tout marc en compte le une copine
à la cancha look ici que la motta - le
bon site est bon le site et cas c'est
vrai on a fait casser des grandes ligues
ne veut pas trop un contexte ça et bana
talmi un septième ça et la mana mana
habite c est ca là que mal à travail sur
le lazaret numéro un malin travaille
dessus le site et un été merveilleux
parce que m'a découvert en fin de compte
ce que banalité dit est vrai et là
maintenant
lena le lazaret numéro deux que nous
dans cette cité là aussi par un combat
et mais aurait bien que ja mais lyon
quoi voilà
sauf qu'elle était finie quand la
commence à enlever que dépendent malade
et puis c'est bt des femmes le don mais
des caps
c'est un bon départ à la retraite
vous avez 18 ans plus les traités habana
qui fuit de partout qui est ouverte et
elle perd 6 à la gare et veille
le train s'arrête pas dans la nouvelle
disant c'est bien être de square à la
demande à dallas j'ai maté une telle
envie d'y emmener votre mariage
- vtm ça on était très content à bas la
dense forêt d'othe tout est bien qui en
vivent pas de monde ne serait pas mais
ce mouvement s'est offerte une invention
on aime parce que ban a tiré sur
quelqu'un que l'avis d'autres ninard
tout ça il paie environ
c'est ce à quoi tient
alors gagner avec l'arabe mois mais
panahi siens m'arrive s'il ya un peu
plus de dix ans est comme un rêve à la
grande chaloupe pour moi c'était surtout
la côte est l'héroïne de la série numéro
2 c'était pour moi il simule était un
peu haut du temps noté d'un endroit de
mystère et des paiements et des lycées
c'est peut être là beaucoup de monde est
passé par ici tout est dans tout les
ancêtres de la réunion est passé là mais
c'est ça qui fait son charme et de voir
le bâtiment tel que l'ine mais c'est ça
qui ramène à nous dans le temps passé et
même viré dans le mystère
alors je me présente je m'appelle
olivier chez un habitant de la rue
charlot mes parents sont réunionnais
sont originaires de la grande chaloupe
aussi mais moi personnellement je suis
né en métropole et en 2004 a à mes 22
ans j'ai eu l'appel de la terre comme on
dit et je suis retournée ici est sûre
la grande chaloupe dans l'ancienne
maison de mes parents justement alors
arrivé ici à la grande chaloupe
même à la découvre le lazaret et le
lazaret en fin de compte c'est comme si
le bâtiment t cause avec moins et
la donne a moins envie de
savoir un peu plus sur tout ça quoi et
justement ya tellement de choses à
apprendre que dernièrement encore mal a
appris que le médecin qui était soigne
les engagés ici ben comment il y avait
écrit un roman et ce roman justement me
trouve que il emmène à nous
vers la poésie et me trouve qu'il
faudrait pas des enchante celui là quoi
en fait
lorsque je me fut un peu remis je vis
que j'étais en face d'une belle vallée
où un torrent à sec avait son lit au
centre et dont les bords semblable aux
parois escarpées d'une grande chaloupe
se relever en formant de paute montagne
il me serait impossible de dire laquelle
archipel appartenait cette île mais elle
était située sous les latitudes chaude
en raison de la nature des arts chacune
de ces constructions avaient un étage un
vaste escalier en pierres taillées avec
une rampe en fer battu on comptait sur
chaque façade plus de 80 fenêtre il y
avait un magasin très spacieux où l'on
enfermait les vivres et les vêtements
une salle immense et séparée qui je
crois a été affecté aux malades car il
me fait absolument défendu de m'en
approcher à midi sous les rayons d'un
soleil étincelant les vêtements bigarrée
de couleurs vives sont attachés à des
piquets ou étendu sur la corde
dans ces longues salle éclairée à
l'huile de jean jolly chacun choisi par
terre sa place accoutumé
hélas peuple à tort sur plusieurs
rangées
côte à côte le long des lambris ou en
ligne
vers le milieu du vaste édifice
alors arrive ici et là des points
produits elle n'arrivait pas le train
est arrivé par le train et le marchand
de bois le tout nouvel arrivant qui
habitent ici il fallait passer à côté de
ça les avait c'était l'arrêt numéro 1 et
la série numéro 2 avait un vieux un
vieux qui habitait de danse mais la
salle est de loin l'équipe n'était pas
comme ça maintenant
c'était un autre bâtiment
je suis à l'avant et ça servait aux
chantiers qui regarde les gens qui
travaillaient sur route en corniche
quand je n'ai pas hésité pas ouvrir la
route vers en 63 mais c'était pas ouvrir
ici
donc voilà on essaiera new love emi
habitat revanche alou m'a donné ici non
pas par la lâcheté le terrain à la
grande chaloupe depuis en 62 et donc mal
a grandi
comme assez longtemps ici depuis jusqu'à
l'âge de 17 ans donc nous partez à
l'école vers la possession donc
obligatoirement ne dépasse par le lazari
et le lazaret nous dans notre enfance
c'est que nous te fais pas trop un
compte avec parce que par rapport que
nous l'avait pas d'histoire dont c'était
un bâtiment abandonné et et maintenant
elle a été restaurée et en restaurant
belle à la concernant qui a connu près
d'une visite fait maintenant appeler un
touriste qui vient et c'est parce par le
lazaret que
la grance avocat était plus posé
moi
à